our land burned down five years ago and
what is mainly growing back are these
mimosa trees are also known as Acacia if
nothing is done to the land it's likely
that causes fire again
to have a better fire break and more
space we want to clear the area behind
base camp we have to chop a bunch of
mimosa trees But realize we don't know
much about them
so we are going to visit an expert that
studied them for 20 years and also try
to build things with them ourselves
welcome to a new project Camp update
[Music]
so as you can see here is the kitchen
container and here is the Mimosa Forest
where it starts we already started
shopping down here but there is a lot to
go still so before we couldn't start
this work because we were not allowed to
use power tools as everything was super
dry
soil is now super wet rain started and
we are now allowed to start full on
super dense bushy area so it's difficult
to go through a lot of Fallen trees
around
and if we find a native tree we for sure
keep it so this is a public road and
we'll mark the end of our cutting
session this is one of the edges but we
will just leave a bit of a line of trees
so we protect a bit from The View and
this is the other Edge so we opened this
last year from the lake until base camp
so we could water the plant and we will
stop until here
this is the team it will be a bit
fluctuating because it will be rainy and
people will come and go all the time but
we're ready to start
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
to compress your wood so it takes up
less space
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we've been clearing the patch for a
couple of days now hard work but still
cannot see much change lots of bushes
and trees anyway our main reason to chop
down the mimosas is to reduce fire risk
our neighbor and our new experienced the
fire in 2017 and he has it clear is
my major
problem
so we are taking Antonio's advice and we
will clear a 10 meter security area
around our base camp before we continue
with the rest of the patch
oh my God
[Applause]
yeah
come on yep
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this guy you see cutting me Moses hasn't
been properly introduced yet he is the
youngest in our group full of energy and
fun
hey I'm Tasman 21 years old and freshly
imported from Australia just like my
mate the mimosas but not so invasive
I've been traveling for a couple years
and come with a strong passion for
plants and Native species I came to Camp
to expand my knowledge on construction
and sustainable Land Management
outside of Camp I enjoy challenging
myself and exploring natural spaces
in the future I'd like to move more into
natural resource management but also
still lots to learn alrighty enough
talking let's get back to work
as good as it's gonna get
that's fun
where was it in the brambles
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
at the moment the space around the lake
is quite narrow it's hard to access it
this is why we will take away this
mimosas dead trees and rumbles in
between so we create open space around
the lake to take on next steps
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Lake and we have a clear patch from the
back of the container up until here now
and the next step is gonna continue at
the back
[Music]
in the middle of all of these mimosas
that we have been clearing out we found
a native tree and we drawn you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we made a few different organized piles
this is pile number one with small burnt
sticks they will be chipped these are
piles number two which is burned wood as
well but too thick to be wood chipped
and this is pile number three it's the
top of the fresh mimosas that will also
be for the wood chipper this pile
doesn't have a number we don't really
know what to do it's the pile of the
brumbles and it's not so cool if it's
still on the floor because it just gets
stuck in our clothes we make it into a
pile we can't really make Fires at the
moment and we don't know what to do with
it for now just lays here these two
piles are the ends of the fresh mimosas
because they are fresh it's not very
easy for the wood chipper to chip them
and they are also a bit too thick so we
separate them into different sizes and
they will be used for different projects
as you will see although Mimosa is all
over Portugal seems that people don't
make stuff with them the wood is not
very strong but we will do some
experiments to find some applications
trying different techniques like carving
weaving landscaping or carpentry let's
start with Martin and Emma
so for our Mimosa project we're gonna do
some wood carving I am going to make a
wash powder measuring spoon I'm gonna
make a back scratcher for my carving I'm
going to use a hatchet carving knife my
spoon knife
my uh chisels most of the time and a
wooden Hammer but I saw that Frank is
using it at the moment so I think I'm
gonna make one myself real quick those
are from emotion three let's start let's
go
this is for my hammer
here's your Hammer ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ah it feels good nice sharp knife
going to use my spoon carving knife now
to make the hollow space in the spoon
we've got all these cultural differences
about how much washing powder should be
used we've got this american guy
says you have to load the whole thing
they always like to go big you know
we've got this German guy who says it
should be uh 98.5 they're really precise
so to settle this matter I call my
mother
she said it should be 110 so we're going
for that you
know modern yeah gender roles
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I think I'm finished with the spoon it's
got a nice scoop
nice interior I gave a little bit of
sanding on the edges to smoothen them
but I'm Gonna Leave
all these cutting marks I like the
Aesthetics of that now the wood carving
is done it works actually it's nice oh
oh that felt good eh I found it
[Music]
hey come on ah you also finished your
piece yeah you do I see wow that's a
nice back scratcher yeah you did a nice
job too man
hey there I'm Rita and you volunteer
here at project camp and my mimosa
project is a weaved basket made out of
the bark of the mimosas this was our
first prototype our first experiment
with weaving for this one we decided to
go thinner
so the strips are helped with I think
the other ones were around four
centimeters and these ones are around
two centimeters I would say and we
doubled the amount of strips because of
that so we went from having 12 strips so
six by six to twenty four
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
is you have
vertical lines of material
and then horizontal lines I'm just going
to see
where the last strip is so if it was
under then this one has to be over and
this one is over so I go under and just
repeat the process
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
it's always good to have a spray bottle
in hand so that you can
Mist your working in
or even the basket itself
and make it more flexible so that you
can shape it
[Music]
our basket is finished it's been three
or four days since I weaved it and you
saw the final result now it's pretty dry
it's not going anywhere I kind of like
how rough it is so I don't really mind
that there is some irregularity and
the shape isn't totally Square
the most importantly it's waste free so
you are not purchasing any materials
it's like zero kilometer material supply
maybe this would be a really cool
research model for you guys to join in
and maybe give some other ideas for
weaving looking forward to find more
uses for the Mimosa Park because we seem
to have an infinitive supply of them
let's see what else
happens in the meantime
[Music]
so now that we have this beautiful Pizza
table that we also use as a workspace
during the week it turns out that most
of our chairs are too low and we cannot
work
at a comfortable position here
and so I thought it would be nice to
have a bar stool to be able to do that
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
number one is ready three more to go
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey guys I'm making a video here
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is ready now but as you can see it's not
very comfortable yet it needs a seat and
let's see if Charlie and Reed can do
something about that
laughs
[Music]
there it goes
[Music]
[Music]
now that the stool is finished Martine
can sit at the proper height with a
straight back and work happily
[Applause]
all right we're next to the community
center
down on this slippery Hill
and uh Liz and I are going to set up
some steps from the Mimosa cut near base
camp so let's see how we go
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
that's the stairs
I think that turned out pretty well
hopefully we can get up the hill a bit
easier now in the rain
and yeah it was good to use some of
these mimosas from up the hill give them
another life
yeah
cool
so we've been spending quite a lot of
time with the mimosa trees by now but we
realize we actually don't know too much
about them we started looking on the
internet to get to know them better in
some places Mimosa is a symbol for
women's International Day it can have
healing properties and many colleges
like it because it grows fast so it
creates a lot of organic Mass to build
soil that retrains water and moist seems
like a useful plant but most local
people around here actually seem to hate
these trees calling them invasive
useless and fire risk we wanted to
understand more about this so we went to
have a chat with an expert that has been
working for over 20 years with mimosas
to see how it feels about it
my name is Manuel Manuel fernange I
started to study acacia's more than two
decades ago Mimosa is a common name that
we apply to a plant that the botanists
call Acacia de Alberta it comes from
Australia from the southeast Australian
from Tasmania there it is part of the
under story of eucalyptus forests and if
some day the eucalypts at chop down or
there's a forest fire or some other
disturbance than the mimosas they find a
window of opportunity and for several
decades they become dominant until the
eucalyptus grow again they proliferate a
lot by seed they produce lots of seeds
every year they also when you chop down
one Acacia regenerates but also the root
system has the property of Amity think
new individuals a single stem of mimosa
May grow more than two meters per year
that's a lot of course and they don't
have what we may call natural enemies as
they do on their original
area in in Australia and Tasmania
nowadays it is not easy to use these
plants because they their use is
forbidden by law
only in Special Occasions in special
situations we can use them but I know
some experiences of use for making
compound for agricultural uses and first
three uses also for making charcoal it
is very suitable as fire wood and of
course the bark of these plants is
widely used for the tanning industry not
any longer in Portugal but in countries
like South Africa and Brazil
we can say that is more or less
flammable than other species or other
types of vegetation depends on the
surrounding landscape when did it rain
for the last time depends on the the age
of the the plants that depends on a lot
of factors
most of the people they have some
difficulty in understanding that mimosas
are proliferating because of the way
because of the way we manage our lands
they are more like a symptom they are
more like a consequence than anything
than a cause of ecological change fire
is the trigger in most of the occasions
but not only fire every mobilization of
the soil
triggers this species I think mimosas in
some occasions they might even be an
opportunity an ecological opportunity
and the only thing we need is to
start to research we feel we know much
more about mimosas now we have to deal
with them but also we can use them and
in the future much more ideas will come
along
you are also welcome to join the
discussion in the research module
following the link in the description
where you can also find the full
interview with the expert
but still one thing to do to finish the
job we call a friend to bring his wood
chipper and we will chip off some piles
to cover our land
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so if you have a tractor laying around
you can donate it to us could the a
tractor that can handle this kind of
wood chipper so we can thread this get a
royal reminder start to create salt and
regenerate Overland
foreign
ly the space is completely cleared and
we have easy access to it I will show it
to you
this is exactly how it looks like it's
now very much fire resilient and the
neighbors are super happy and we are
much more safe wood chips are really
brilliant and we spend the whole day
chipping it but we have still loads of
piles to go but for now we just give
back all this organic material to the
land
there is some water lines as this place
is quite steep this will help to slow
down the water to run through and we'll
just keep more water on this part of the
land
this Lake was aggressively open before
so there is a lot of erosion happening
and the path was coming shorter and
shorter now we can just walk kind of
easily and access some places easier
look
we still have loads of piles to process
and we have to check how we will do that
it was a hard work we worked a lot but
it was super fun as well and this is how
it looks like for now
next week's video is going to be
challenges so bring up your questions in
the comments for us to answer
thanks for watching and don't forget to
subscribe
if you like what we do you can support
us on patreon and your help would be
highly appreciated